it with reaction house oversight
committee chair James comr and chairman
of the house Ways and Means Committee
Jason Smith uh Congressman comr let's
talk about the war room that they' set
up I think against you especially uh but
also against Jason I'm sure Jim Jordan
and and probably anybody in the media
that dares to tell this story your
reaction well you they wouldn't have to
set up a war room Sean if they would
just provide the information that we've
requested I don't think we've requested
anything out of the ordinary we want to
know the correspondence that Joe Biden
used with the pseudonyms between the
government and himself pertaining to
Ukrainian policy we want to know any
emails that had Hunter Biden copied on
them from the government this is stuff
that should be public record and with
respect to their bank records Joe Biden
had no problem with releasing Donald
Trump's tax returns uh Joe Biden said he
would be the most transparent president
in the history we've already proven that
his family got $20 million from foreign
Nationals they can't say a single thing
they did to earn the money so obviously
we're suspicious about their personal
bank accounts all we want to do is see
their personal bank accounts to make
sure that Joe Biden wasn't getting his
10% and and make sure that Hunter Biden
was uh was telling the truth when he
said that he had to give his salary half
his salary to his father did have you in
in that 1023 form with the trusted F uh
FBI in Forman talking to the CEO of
barisma he talks about 5 million to one
Biden 5 million to another Biden and it
will take you 10 years to find out where
how we pay them the money have you been
able to trace that $10 million do you
believe we we're still looking for that
well I as you know we found2 million we
do have leads uh we believe and suspect
that there are offshore accounts but
that's something we'll discuss later and
Jason Smith may want to discuss that at
some point in the near future but it but
it's at the end of the day what they
said in that 1023 form where they used
various bank accounts that is consistent
with what we've seen in Romania in China
in Russia and Ukraine where they use
various bank accounts and various shell
companies so when when that FBI form was
written no one knew the Biden's had
shell companies no one knew they had 170
suspicious activity reports where six
different banks accused them of money
laundering that's what that FBI form
alleges before anyone knew
about the shell companies and the moneya
laundering so it fits a pattern that
we've seen in other countries let me ask
you Jason Smith House Republicans now
have been accusing Biden's attorneys of
intimidating the IRS whistleblowers in a
letter to the AG attorney general meric
Garland do you have evidence that that
took place this these intimidation
efforts are taking place and and why did
you have people in in Biden's White
House talk to the uh whistleblowers
prior to to that testimony before your
committee Sean one of the the great
examples is the letter that Hunter
Biden's lawyer sent to me at in the end
of June in that letter they tried to
intimidate me in regards to my own
investigation and to discredit the two
Brave IRS whistleblowers that came
forward Sean it tried to say that their
actions of coming forward to the Ways
and Means Committee was illegal and that
they were breaking the law and so that
is why we sent the letter to attorney
General Garland is to is to see the
documents the emails the corresponden
that Hunter Biden's lawyers had with the
Department of Justice and trying to push
for prosecution of these two Brave IRS
whistleblowers that came before us let
me tell you today we interviewed one of
the four individuals that we subpoena
Sean an IRS employee and and just like
the other three that we've done over the
last four days they confirmed what the
IRS whistleblowers were saying and and
that is prosecutor Weiss had to get
permission hire up the food Change chain
in the Biden Administration to bring
charges and to to move ahead in this
investigation against the president's
son how are people going to want to come
forward if this is how we're going to
treat whistleblowers I thought Democrats
like whistleblowers
congressmen they should absolutely
they're supposed to love whistleblowers
but that's in fact what this letter did
it it would try to scare additional IRS
whistle or any whistleblowers of any
kind to come forward they are trying to
to scare people from coming and telling
the truth but let me tell you the
information's coming out these IRS
whistleblowers has done a phenomenal job
and no one no one has countered what the
IRS whistleblowers have said their their
statements have stayed the same the
Biden Administration is the one that
continues to sing from a different tune
all right chairman Smith and chairman
chairman comr thank you for the updates
we appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else